welcome to the big brother season 18
house oh I feel like I'm an airport way
to shut whoa each room is a destination
after you have departed from this gate
this is Tokyo this is Tokyo I look okay
Godzilla
what's Tokyo without some neon lights
and Godzilla all right so we start in
Tokyo we're on the phone in Tokyo but I
feels London already because the red
phone booth yeah we are in Hawaii now
because that's gotta be America's
favorite vacation spot for him I know
this is the head of household own king
bed look at this even a microphone right
here in the shower hey we can't have any
spot where any two house guests can have
a private conversation nope no 87
cameras in more than 110 microphones
we'll keep tabs on this season's
houseguests every move as they try to
last 99 days for the $500,000 grand
prize there's no safe zone you can be
heard every single place in the yard in
the back of the yard just right down the
center we've got it we've got him
everywhere
the backyard got a makeover too with a
new pool and a spot to get swimsuit
ready we're gonna put in a CrossFit gym
what yes you do CrossFit I could tell
you they know I don't do crosses I have
trust me if you touch hard there's a lot
of softness I just can't believe it's
lasted 18 seasons and I've been there
since the beginning I mean who would
have thunk it at this rate we'll be
going like cousins like Bob Barker's
going on forever
big brother 72 it's Julie Chang
you